you Wow I was close babe
[Applause]
[Music]
you
there's nothing better than hanging out
with burger scholar George Motz aka the
moats man especially when barreling down
a Texas Highway in a big pickup truck in
search of the best primary source
hamburgers in America
today's epic road trip takes us through
the Dallas area to learn about some very
special burgers in the heart of beef
country giddyup
[Music]
[Music]
Oh exes live in Texas alright here we
are on the open road why are we in Texas
we're in Texas because Texas has some of
the greatest hamburgers in America
unquestionably I've been unaffected by
time and trend these are burgers that
really right called primary source
burgers they've been around for a long
time they're unchanged or uncomplicated
and perfect you are literally in that
you're in the bosom of beef country
right here the bosom of the country
we're in Dallas because I wanted to show
you a place that had a lot of variety so
we're gonna hit three spots today we're
gonna hit herds hamburgers which is
where the hell outside of Dallas in
Jacksboro Texas then we're gonna go to a
place called knife knife steakhouse
which is a high-end Steakhouse with a
really good uncomplicated burger and
then the plan is to hit Keller's
drive-in classic old-school
drive-in restaurant in Texas Oh have you
throw up let me refill your throw no
thanks I think that's what they're made
for
that's it yeah oh it's packed already
we're here at 11:11 20 that's already
full it's lunch but look at it this is
something it looks like someone's house
right it would yes this is never judge a
book by it's cover
no never judge a hamburger joint by its
cover
[Music]
this day he's Tina he's hungry where it
hurts we are far outside of any city
forget Dallas we're us for far outside
of any city far outside of Dallas the
rolling hills of North Texas right now
you always seem to take me to places
where I feel like I'm traveled through
time you did try out the time you fell
back in time this place opened over a
hundred years ago it's still a same
family paleo burger joint in Texas
fourth-generation
this burger is a primary source burger
this burger goes back to the beginning
of the hamburger age
the method is unlike anything you'll see
it has a big wad like two pounds three
pounds of ground chuck on the flat tops
of mountain to be any carves off what he
needs or patty and somehow he knows how
to judge what a patty should look like
and then he forms into a loose of
loosely formed patty smashes it with a
trowel and that's it
you ready to eat always ready to eat so
we have two different burgers here here
they are yeah Cheers
hey look at that buddy oh you smell it
oh it's so deep that's a big shells it
looks like the bun is toasted but it's
not toasted with butter it's toasted
with beef grease oh that's beef tallow
not butter few of the old fish which is
a pickles mustard nut right I have the
more contemporary version which is all
the way it's tomatoes pickles onion
lettuce Oh another sherry though manner
I can't I can't wait to try this
oh right that beepers oh there's so much
going on and such as a little burger mmm
big beef tallow yeah it's intense right
on the bottom bun almost has like this
empanada effect yes true it's really
part of the flavor I think from this
printer it comes from the fact that is
it's like a 60 plus year-old griddle
over there yeah but Dani is fourth
generation family member
okay family owner what he's doing over
there is 100% method how many burgers
you think you've made in since you've
been working here come on no we didn't
know anything I I would even know what
to guess I count the money in the drawer
at end of the day and it's never enough
like a true restaurateur I'm Danny heard
of flip burgers at hearts and burgers
family-owned business since 1960 the
first time the George was in here I
think was on the second edition of his
book he just showed up one morning with
the camera we didn't know who he was the
real friendly guy you know and so he's
watching me cook over there he goes well
how did y'all come up with this unique
way of making burgers and I looked at in
kinda like what are you talking about
what's unique about it it's the only way
I've ever seen it done I don't know how
else you would do it it's just a simple
product but it's consistent generation
after generation day after day Hertz
hamburgers established 1916 and
Jacksboro Texas there's no big fancy
neon sign there's not a bunch of signs
and says come here to hamburger it's
actually it's actually set back from the
street it looks like it's a whole
problem in a home at some point it's a
big pecan tree right throw in the entire
thing of that tree blocks the entire
yeah if you didn't know and you just
drove by an oasis yeah you would almost
think that you're just driving by a
house how did you find this place I went
to great lengths so we could shoot here
today I'll tell you what happened they
don't this thinner of a phone here and
houses no phone yeah I don't hear
anything ringing dad no phone and I but
I do have Danny's cell phone number
oh but I won two years ago I called it
and it was disconnected oh man
know what we gonna do so I went on
Google Earth Google Street View and I
found the business next door I found
there their sign outside or the phone
number on the side with a name and so I
called them and I said hey any way you
can give me a message to Danny
okay I'm walking over there right now
and they ask you walk the message across
the parking lot and Danny saw my number
he said I know George and he coming back
right away that's some deep
Investigatory whereas the only took a
few minutes that not everybody's totally
connected to the internet on the rest of
the world they don't need to be right
and then up or do you have a world class
this isn't on an app it's a world class
burger that is disconnected from the
world
well whoa its history and I think if you
really want to taste a piece of history
you come out here it's true
and and you have to get hurt you just
have to have a nerds burger you got to
go fine if time you have to get out
there and find this stuff to me as like
a restaurant puris as a burger Paris
yeah to see something like this alive
and functioning yeah and functioning
whoa well a high functioning gives me
hope yeah for the future yeah
pitstop number one herds hamburgers the
throwback burger just to go
Wayfarer and stranger
while traveling
in this world of woe yet there's no
sickness
[Music]
next time on the burger show this is a
burger show burger meat cheese bun this
is living proof that in a steak house
you don't have to go crazy with Aeolis
and truffle [ __ ] we're heading to a
Dallas steak house to try one of the
most famous burgers in America I can't
wait to taste the burbs I don't think
that's a good accent and we're gonna cap
off our road trip at one of Georgia's
favorite places in OG classic driving
establishment there are so many burgers
to get in the Dallas area
I tell people they can pick one burger
they're coming to Dallas
just do something favor and drive in
Keller's you have to stay tuned
[Music]
you
what's up everybody it's having Kyle out
of the burger show make sure you turn on
your notifications smash that like
button smash that subscribe button and
thank you for watching